everybody so let's get started with the
today's session so this morning we have
three thoughts all about polynomials and
our first speaker will be Mohit Singh
now of Georgia Tech who will talk about
some interesting work he's been doing
with the nice invitation and it's great
to be back here
this is joined both ways Sasha who's
here in audience as well a lot of this
work was done when both of us were at
Microsoft Research so I'll talk about
maximizing sub determinants but I'll
really there's a motivation also for
this problems comes as a subset
selection problems as well so let me
first introduce you to motivation and
then I'll formally define the problem
and try to give you some like
interesting relaxed polynomial
relaxation for this problem general
problem that we want to study is that if
I give you a corpus of items I want to
select a subset of them and I want this
subset to be as diverse as
representative of the corpus that I have
and simultaneously I want them to
satisfy some combinatorial constraint
right one simple constraint could be
that I can't make too many of them
it does have cardinality constrain or
more combinatorial constraints could be
we want to be the set repeat to be a
base of our independent set of a Metroid
in that we'll study a special case of
this mostly in this talk okay
so this is a very general problem it has
been studied from many different angles
so let me give you one motivation also
for this this was this and taking images
from calisca and tasks and which exactly
formulates our problem so one motivation
did say is for example you want to do
image search for Jaguar if you just want
to do it from relevance basically you
should expect to see these kind of
results but if you also want to have
diversity somehow you should see all
different kinds of Jaguars in your
output okay so how does one model this
problem and one way one way they suggest
is to actually just assign a vector in
some high dimensions to each of these
two each of these items in my corpus so
each of your dimensions possibly could
relate to some feature that you are
trying to look for
the new objects and the diversity of any
subset of items that I pick I would just
compute the volume of the parallelepiped
spanned by these vectors and that'll be
my diversity and why does it make sense
right is that if my two items are
similar the vectors hopefully would be
very close to each other right if my
representation of these vectors is
somewhat honest so I should expect the
volume to be small and if they are this
quite different then the vectors should
be somewhat orthogonal and I will get a
larger volume that me so just some
notation I'm going to put all the
vectors as columns of a matrix and I'm
going to call that matrix V and L I'm
going to call the correlation matrix
which will be basically have inner
products of VI and VJ and our goal okay
so our goal is to come like objective we
are considering is the volume of the
polypeptide which is exactly the
determinant of V V transpose V B where
VB is a sub matrix that I have u 4d
restricted if I restrict this matrix to
the columns that I selected like the
columns are indexed by items and if I
select set B of my items those are those
columns and the volume is exactly the
determinant of this it's a it's a or
just a determinant of the principle sub
matrix for the correlation matrix for
these vectors and formally the problem
that we're going to study is to maximize
this quantity
okay therefore getting the square root
for now maximize the determinant of V B
transpose V B and B is the set B I have
to select from which is feasible under
some combinatorial constrains for
example the simplest one is just a
cardinality constraint I have to select
K of these vectors more general
constraints that we will study in the
stock or the partition matrix can strain
so I will what what I'm thinking of is
that I give you a partition of my ground
set of p1 through PL and from each
partition I specify you how many vectors
to pick
yeah so this is actually they call it
the constrain map inference problem in
determinated point processes I will not
go into this connection so much so there
are other motivation it's a very natural
problem in convex geometry so this was
really started starting from work of
Kashi on where the problem they said is
I want given a collection of n vectors
in Rd and I want to find the simplex
which is inside the convex hull of these
vectors of the maximum volume okay and
many people in audience are here who
have started this as well and there is a
simple transformation to actually reduce
this problem to the problem that we have
or subject to cardinality constraint
there are there is another problem which
is also very closely related is the
geography and placement problem which
has been started by John Lee if he's and
he called it the constraint maximum
entropy is sampling problem mmm
again it can be reformulated essentially
at this but they consider more general
constraints maps are constraints and
other constraints as well there are
other relations of this problem to
experimental design in statistics and
also in discrepancy theory I will let
you see the references if you are
interested in those connections so there
lot of work being done on this problem
from many different areas
I will mainly focus on approximation
algorithm because that's what this talk
is about so let me tell you the previous
work and approximation algorithms most
of the work has been done on the
cardinality constraint some of the
references we solved before so and
starting work from Kashi on and so on
there was a series of line of work and
finally there was this nice work by
niccolò Sachi over here who gave a 1
over e to the K approximation for this
problem so they really we are trying to
find a subset of size K which has which
maximizes or determinant of the
principle sub matrix of my PhD matrix
the correlation matrix that I give you
and once you just notice this looks like
exponential factor but that's really the
right kind of approximation factors that
you should expect because we really
computing volumes right like so in in K
dimensions so we should expect
exponential in K kind of approximations
and in particular it is known it's that
it's np-hard to get better
and see to the key approximation for
some see less than one so these kind of
results are actually known as well
so what our work okay so before I move
tell you what our work is one other nice
connection is to a rich body of
literature which has developed over the
last few years on some constraint
somewhat a maximization problem in
particular we can actually model our
problem as a some aalam optimization
problem because I could just define the
set function where the value of a set B
is just a log of our objective for that
set okay so in it's not very hard to
show this is a model like it's simple
inequalities to check and this problem
has been started for exactly Metroid and
other constraints as well unfortunately
all of them assume non negativity while
this function is not necessarily
non-negative in particular we are taking
loss of numbers these numbers could be
even be 0 actually so it might look a
very technical thing but actually it
really puts the problem into a different
viewer the problems the none of these
techniques and so on some generalize
hopefully there is more formal
connection one can take from the
machinery that has been developed over
here unfortunately we were not
successful to do that ok so so let me
tell you now what do we do we study this
problem subject to partition constraints
so we generalize from the cardinality
constraint to partition constraints so
more formally I'm going to give you this
n by n positive semi-definite matrix L
so rows and columns are indexed by u so
this is a correlation matrix and I'm
going to give you a partition of my
ground set so and the basis would be
exactly a set such that you pick exactly
small bi number of elements from Part A
and a goal is to pick a basis such that
the principal sub matrix for this basis
B is the determinant of that principal
sub matrix is maximized
Fabia's our input so we are given
exactly we are given a partition Metroid
with includes that we are given P 1
through P L as well as these numbers bi
good and basically what we show this is
in joint focus our show is that there is
a 1 over e to the K approximation for
this problem as well
subject to partition contains K so k is
the size of the basis that we want to
pick
so there are a few things that I want to
get across to in this talk the one most
important one is that I'm going to give
you a new pommel optimization problem
for this problem which is a relaxation
of this problem and that's I feel is
something I want to get across and after
that I'll just give you a very simple
randomized algorithm which is what we
analyzed and some of some connections to
the theory of stable promise and in
particular to permanent would that show
up that show up in our analysis I'll try
to get some idea across why those
connections actually appear okay
so before I tell you our relaxation
let's go back to the carnality
constraint and see what can be done over
there so there is a standard concave
program one can life there's some
notation I want to just set up again LSR
matrix that I give you PSD matrix I can
do it so let's key decomposition and get
these vectors again notation this I'm
going to call for any set SVS to be the
matrix we're at restrict my matrix to
the columns corresponding to s for this
talk I'm just going to assume the
dimension of this matrix that I have is
the same as the number of the elements
the time I'm picking actually so our
results also hold more generally but for
this talk I'm just going to focus on
that maybe I'd say a few words for the
general case when the number of vectors
we are picking is smaller than the
dimension of the matrix in that case
actually it's very simple to see that
the determinant of our objective for any
set s if it's a feasible set well it's
this is just the sum of the outer
products of these rank one matrices for
the vectors in a set okay and really by
definition this is determinant V s
transpose V s but these back now these
matrices are square matrices because we
assume in k equal to D right I'm picking
K vectors and the dimension is D and
kiddin so DS at K by D matrices but now
I'm assuming K equal to D so I can just
write V s transpose V s as we SBS
transpose the determinant is really the
same and this is just the outer product
so now once once you see this objective
it's very easy to write a relaxation
because I could have decision variables
for every vector whether I pick it in my
solution or not and I just put that as
my variables so I want to maximize this
objective and I place constraints on my
Eck's that it has to be in the convex
hull of the feasible set okay so
cardinality constraints the field the
convex of the feasible set is pretty
simple you just place bound constraints
and say the sum of the x's is equal to K
right this is really pretty
straightforward well see this objective
is not actually a concave but it's LA
concave so in sum we can still optimize
it and solve this relaxation and this is
the relaxation that had been started in
the previous work for the cardinality
constraint and Niccolo actually showed
that the integral the gap of this is
bounded by exactly 1 over e to the K
okay exactly this relaxation of course
once you look at this it should be clear
there's nothing special about the
cardinality constraint we can strike
this relaxation for any set of
constraints that we are placing in
particular the partition constraints
that we are trying to understand we
could still write a similar relaxation
and that's the first thing one wants one
should do and that's what we also did so
the write this relaxation so now our
constraints on X objective remains the
same the constraints on X is that it's a
convex hull of again all the feasible
sets all the bases that we have again
this convex hull is pretty
straightforward to write it's just that
you are in in the hypercube and the for
any part the num fractions are values
that you have for the vectors in that
part must add up to be I right it's the
same as clearly it should be easy to see
it's a relaxation and again you can
solve it that's fine the problem is that
this is not a good relaxation now in
particular it cannot detect whether the
answer is 0 or not and I just want to
stress this a bit so let's see in the
previous case when I just want to pick
any K vectors the answer is like in the
previous case the answer is nonzero as
long as I have D linearly independent
vectors right I can just pick them now I
know the volume will be nonzero it might
be bad but at least I'm exactly that's a
simple way to check I just should just
check the rank of the matrix L right if
it is equal to K then I am done which is
any way which I was assuming over here
unfortunately here this relaxation does
not check the answer is 0 but
claiming still claiming this problem is
actually easy like we can solve in
polynomial time when the answer is zero
or nonzero okay so what do I want is the
the problem is is there a collection of
vectors K vectors such that from part P
I I pick exactly bi vectors such that
the volume of the parallelepiped spanned
by them is nonzero which is equal to
saying that these vectors are linearly
independent if the vectors would be the
vectors I will pick is linearly
dependent I know their volume will be
nonzero it could be really bad possibly
but that just shows me I can actually
solve this problem as a Maitre
intersection problem okay so what one
Metroid is the linear Metroid generated
by these vectors the other Metroid is
the partition matrix
that I have okay if there is a common
basis to these Metroid's random answer
is non non zero if there is no common
basis then the answer is zero to my of
my problem that I'm trying to solve and
the point is this relaxation cannot
detect this simple fact it cannot solve
meter intersection problem okay
good so what do we do okay so what we do
is actually write some what we're
looking at and let's program our so bear
with me
so what we are going to do is write a
saddle point problem Max and min over
some function that I'm going to write
and a function is going to be I'm just
going to plug in a new variable Y for
each vector okay as well that similar to
what we had before and this time I'm
going to minimize or why it should be
clear I claim that this log of this
function is concave in X so you
shouldn't expect it to be it's not
linear so you don't sure shouldn't
expect it to be convict's in Y as well
it's really the same set of variables
intuitively that I'm putting in so I
really shouldn't be min like shouldnt be
able to minimize if i just words linear
constraints q is some constraints that
I'm going to put exactly right so I
cannot think of Q as linear constraints
because it's not concave so it's not
convex and Y right but it but at least
for P I would still key how Cal U or the
same set of constraints that I have but
what Q I'm going to place and this is
what I'm going to observe I'm going to
place some polynomial constraints on Q
on Y which is will be by Q which will
say that for every feasible set if I
look at the product of the variables in
this feasible set they must sum they
must the product must be equal to one
this looks like a funny problem yeah
it's not a yes and no in a sense is not
in the Y variables this one you mean Q
okay okay no no I'm just rewriting over
here I'm writing it as a as a convex all
of vertices here I'm writing it as a
linear inequalities I'm just saying you
can actually get explicit formulation is
the same one I'm rejecting is that the
what do question
I mean like you can have like the base
body top of em one you can have the base
before so you think I could have placed
another constraints right I could have
also please act unfortunate that doesn't
work as well yes so yes yes one that's
one of the reasons of course that's not
the only reason yes that must is clearly
one of the reasons why it doesn't work
but it could happen yes now the answer
will be nonzero yes you are you're
correct because you're only looking at
the base common basis but it could be
the integrality gap will be huge now
okay so I did not go yeah okay it will
be able to detect zero what is non zero
but the integrality gap will be huge
okay but Q these are funny constraints
as I'm placing basically and placing
that the product of the Y variables on
any basis exactly equal to one okay and
of course we give you this polynomial
optimization problem with poor normal
constraints is I am claiming this is a
firstly that is a relaxation and second
you can actually solve it as well
efficiently this relaxation so and two
of the first one let's see why you can
solve it it turns like this I already
claimed to you this function is lock and
cave in X but it turns out it's also
lock and mix in log Y we're a long way I
think of it as actually coordinate wise
okay so if I take coordinate wise log
that this function is actually a convex
in it log of this function is convex and
now if you stay pink of it in log Y
these very these constraints are just
linear constraints right so if once I
really I could have written this for you
in the new set of variables which were
log while but I didn't write it because
I really want to think of these as
polynomial constraints and per normal
variables we will come to this
interpretation later in the talk as well
so right and so optimizing over this you
can optimize over it and this is
actually what is also more other
geometry programs optimizing they in the
problem letting optimization I still
have to show you claim to you I claim to
you that this is a relaxation what does
this program have to do with the problem
that you were trying to solve good so
let me just prove to you that that might
be the only proof that I have
it's a one-line proof actually so I have
to show
this is a relaxation so let me take the
BB the optimal basis and the optimum
value is exactly the determinant of the
principle sub matrix corresponding to B
so I'm going to put X star to be the
indicator vector of this right and I
have to know verify for every Y this
objective is at least the optimum value
okay so let's just do that so let me
look at f of X star comma Y so now I'm
only summing over elements in B because
those are the only variables which are
one rest was zero okay now I think of
this determinant as a polynomial in Y so
this is a D these are d by D matrices
and they're only d of these vectors this
exactly a rank D matrix and it so like
it's a moment of thought will tell you
that actually I can pull out each of Y I
in a as a polynomial and why it's really
Y to the B times this determinant and
now Y to the B for all a feasible sets
that's exactly the constraint we are
placing is exactly equal to one so here
we are really using the fact that
determinant I can write as a polynomial
and each of these Y variables it will be
linear as well as it will be a degree D
polynomial and so the only D variables
so that's the only monomial that will
appear so this is a relaxation that's
good so we can solve it and now my I'm
claiming there is a very simple
randomized rounding algorithm which will
give our our solution so what is the
rounding it's the first rounding you
would think of you just solve this
relaxation let's get the optimal
solution X bar now I'm going to forget
about those Y variables I had this inner
problem why I'm this cone completely
going to ignore it just use X to get
integer solution and I just do a simple
randomized rounding so I go to each part
from each part I have to pick bi
elements so I just look at X X bar by /
bi this is a probability distribution
over elements in Part B I I just do bi
samples from it with a bit of a doubt
replacement it doesn't matter
our guarantees will hold for both of
them and that's the algorithm
so now question how like you so why like
the very was completely disappeared but
they're very crucial for the analysis so
let me try to give you some intuition
why this algorithm actually works with
the guarantee that we are claiming so
for that again I'm going to now consider
the this our objective as a polynomial
in Y so I'm going to just plug in X bar
as the optimum solution and think of it
as a polynomial again it's going to be a
degree K polynomial because K is equal
to D in this case we are assuming and in
Y variables has been linear because
these are rank one matrices so I can
write it as Y to the s times C of s
where C of s is a coefficient of the
monomial y to the S and s will be a
subset a real subset of size K right so
actually there's a typo here this should
be degree K polynomial and in n
variables so just two now see it's
pretty simple to observe that the
optimum solution is really this
minimization problem over this
polynomial leaders are in a problem
right X bar I've picked the optimal
solution of the relaxation so the
optimum solution of a relaxation is
exactly this optimization problem over
our polynomial and it's not very hard to
see for this algorithm the expected
value of the algorithm is up to some
scaling is just some of the certain
coefficients of this polynomial okay and
which coefficients it's exactly the
coefficients which corresponds to the
basis that I have so some of these sets
of size K are feasible sets for our
problem those are exactly the the
coefficients that I'm summing up
this is a very simple calculation like
it's just like a couple of lines so now
to prove the guarantee that we want we
will want a lemma to be that if a if a
polynomial has this form then actually I
know these coefficients must sum up to
more like significantly more 1 over e to
the K more than the optimization problem
with this point moment right that's
exactly that will prove the theorem that
we want and so this here I will take a
slight digression quickly into stable
polynomials so these are basically
multivariate generalization of real
rooted promise the only fact that I
would want for our talk I will not go
into too much of that that the promise
that the kind of promise we are seeing
in we saw are actually stable and the
other thing is that if I take
derivatives of these they remain stable
as well this is this very useful
property when you want to do some
induction on these phenomenons and using
this there was a very nice proof by
Gurewitz of this following fact about
permanence of a matrix which said so
permanent is really like a determinant
except that you don't have a sign of
every permutation that if I take a W
stochastic n by n W stochastic matrix
with non-negative entries it's permanent
is at least n factorial by n to the N ok
and this is a very crucial also to get
deterministic approximation algorithms
for counting number of bipartite
matching in a graph and we he proved it
is actually to prove sim like
essentially a similar theorem the kind
we want so he wrote a polynomial where
which is exactly this polynomial for
this matrix well if you stare at a
moment the coefficient it's a degree n
polynomial so I have one variable for
each column and I have product of n
linear forms where the degree n
prominent variables so there'll be this
mark a linear term and if I look at the
coefficient of that that turns out to be
exactly the permanent of this matrix and
you show that that's at least n
factorial by n to the N times a minimum
over optimization problem where my
constraint I'm placing is that monomial
to be 1
good and this result this general result
he proved for every deer stable
performance and this implies is as a
corollary discharge as well as I just
pointed out to you and essentially what
we need is just really a generalization
of this theorem and that's what
basically what we prove is that if I
give you any polynomial which is degree
K homogeneous multi linear real stable
bunch of conditions and I'm going to
look at the coefficients of this basis
of a partition metroid' that I can bound
with a similar polynomial optimization
problem where I setting the monomials
minimum the constraints are setting the
manami's to be 1 for all the sets for
which I'm summing up the coefficients on
the right hand side and that really
gives us as a corollary the guarantee we
want and that will prove what he'll play
I went fast because of restriction of
time but really they the and this
theorem we can prove as a reduction
proving doing a reduction to the theorem
of for Gurewitz good for general and
there are some technical details that I
would have to be done by will I think
that's fine you can look up the paper if
need be but basically essentially
everything generalizes in the more
general and case as well so let me just
conclude so I gave you a very nice
problem about subset selection problems
that we discussed by diversity you model
it as a maximizing determinant problem
and we looked at means basically the
partition constraints I give you a new
relaxation and a simple randomized
algorithm and some relations to
inequalities on stable polynomials so
the few things one thing is what we get
is a guarantee only on the in
expectation we don't get a bit highly
high probability guarantee or a
deterministic algorithm and that this
problem actually is very close related
to computing miss discriminants of a
matrix of a given like a bunch of
matrices so in some cases those can be
done and we can apply those things to
obtain such results but in generality we
don't know to how to get the same
guarantees as a deterministic or a
randomized algorithm with high
probability the other constraint is of
course you only looked at
partition metroid' may be general
Metroid's actually i like they have been
working that and Nima will give a talk
later in afternoon he will talk
something about that directions as well
and here we looked at one particular
problem and we write this funny looking
economist program are there other
natural combinatorial problems where we
can actually write these convex programs
and at least we could find one more
example which is an a social welfare
problem where we did this and do a
similar analysis and give similar
guarantees as well okay and I left there
thank you
[Applause]
so that would be knapsack tiny for
constrained even if you have a single
part no it's in some sense one has to be
very careful because even the decision
problem whether the answer is zero
versus non zero is going to be hard so
one has to really should not expect
multiplicative approximation algorithms
one really should try to do some kind of
like a linear approximation over there I
believe one should be able to obtain by
criteria approximations over there using
these and follow up results but I
haven't looked up exact factors over
there so you should be able to like they
could be for different constraints you
should have you should be able to direct
with the answer zero which is nonzero if
you are really after a multiplicative
approximation right because in the zero
case your algorithm will do so unless
you are happy with some kind of by
criteria constraints and I believe for
knapsack constrains one should be able
to get some kind of bacterial cells
which will basically reduce the problem
to some Metroid and that you can there
general ways to do that as well
yeah I really don't think so yeah I
think there are reasons because actually
like we are really relying on this
theorem by Gurewitz there are other
methods and different convex programs
one can write where we can where they
have improved this paper by guru it's
and some of the ski who can improve this
factor to something even better than
basically two to the N so possibly I
feel somehow they should be more
connections over there and to obtain a
better factor
[Applause]